Today,
I want to continue talking about energy futures and a alternative choices that
we have to face.
And I,
I think about this as a problem of being on the horns of a,
a quad.
Lemme.
And after I put this slide together,
I was on my way to lecture this morning and I was saying to myself,
it's not really a quad lemme uh,
and being an allergy,
being a Di lemme,
uh,
it,
it really has many more dimensions to it.
Uh,
but the,
uh,
the way that it's being characterized to the public by politicians and those
that are concerned about energy futures is predominantly a choice between
renewables and existing production capacity.
Well,
with respect to fossil fuels,
particularly coal,
uh,
and also our nuclear future that we discussed lacks last week.
Uh,
but the topic that,
uh,
really does not make it onto the agenda,
which is one that I think is crucial is a energy efficiency and what we could
achieve by altering our patterns and consumption.
And I think a as well,
our capacity to read the energy demands of,
of,
uh,
our own daily behaviors in the marketplace.
And in our daily lives,
uh,
make it extremely difficult to do that.
Uh,
so that,
uh,
today I want to concentrate predominantly on the,
the problem of renewables,
uh,
but also,
specifically,
uh,
talk about,
wind energy.
So the National Academy of Sciences prepared a publication that a,
you read hopefully up on the classes server for this week,
uh,
on the potential of a renewables,
particularly wind and solar and solar and wind.
They concluded renewable resources offer a significantly larger total energy
potential than do other domestic renewable resources.
Solar intensity obviously varies across the nation.
Uh,
the land based solar resource exceeds by several thousand fold president annual
US electrical energy demand.
So when is capable of providing at least 10% to 20%,
and in some regions of the country,
potentially higher percentages of current electrical energy demand.
You think about,
uh,
installed capacity,
in the world.
Germany is clearly the leader in terms of megawatt,
uh,
production,
but also percentage of their total electrical energy demands.
And about 2120 4% a,
the u s follows and second at about 18%.
Then Spain,
India,
China,
Denmark.
Uh,
but this,
uh,
this ranking is,
is shifting quite rapidly,
uh,
particularly in China and India and other rapidly developing parts of the world.
Well,
there was a statute that was passed back in 19 in 2005,
a that has really provided a lot of incentive,
economic incentive,
uh,
to the private sector and to government agencies as well too,
to think about a new forms of providing energy,
particularly from renewable resources.
So income from activity,
uh,
may maybe excluded from gross income and not taxed a,
if it's expanded on renewable energy,
uh,
facilities income may be taxed at a lower rate.
Uh,
the expense from the activity may be deducted more quickly.
And those of you that filed your income taxes the last week,
probably,
uh,
do not itemize your deductions,
but deductions are set up in ways that,
uh,
you may depreciate property at a different,
over different lengths of time.
Uh,
you may be able to,
to,
uh,
depreciate a car for example,
over a eight or 10 years or a truck over that period of time.
A house is 32 years and other kinds of products that you might buy,
you could appreciate those of fully in the first year,
meaning that you can get an a,
a total deduction on its value during the year that you purchased it.
Uh,
so that,
uh,
these expenses may be eligible for tax credits as well.
And the deduction is different than a tax credit.
Uh,
abduction deduction is,
uh,
a,
an itemization that,
uh,
you would use to reduce your total,
estimated,
uh,
or adjusted gross income,
whereas a tax credit,
uh,
would be a reduction in your taxes at the end of your return.
Most people would favor taking a tax credit,
it would be more to their advantage.
So these production tax credits that came into being in 2005,
uh,
really had been quite successful as it's demonstrated.
There were previous production credits,
uh,
back in 1999,
and uh,
2001 and 2003.
And then they expired at the end of those years.
So that,
uh,
if you can see this chart,
you can see the rather dramatic decline.
And,
uh,
the,
the populations,
uh,
taking,
taking advantage of of these credits,
there is a business solar tax credit that offers a 30% tax credit for the
purchase of equipment that produces solar electricity business,
fuel cell credits are available,
uh,
that,
that are produced.
Uh,
uh,
even using,
chemicals that are created by fossil fuels.
There's a residential energy efficiency or efficient property credit,
uh,
which is a personal tax credit for eligible eligible,
technologies such as water heaters,
furnaces,
boilers,
heat pumps,
central air conditioners,
building insulation,
windows,
doors and roofs.
And my income taxes.
This year,
I installed a new energy efficient water heater,
uh,
that,
I was able to take a tax credit of a 30% of $2,000,
uh,
which is,
excuse me,
a substantial savings.
Uh,
also,
many states are acting on their own in a topic that we've discussed repeatedly
in the course is a,
if you're thinking about trying to change behavior,
uh,
what level of government is the appropriate government to establish law or,
or,
or policy?
And the federal government has been clearly,
uh,
behind the eight ball.
They'd been delinquent,
uh,
or neglectful of,
passing,
uh,
renewable energy,
standards and,
and,
uh,
creating incentives,
in a way that really,
uh,
had a strong influence on,
on renewable energy production relative to the two particularly fossil fuel
production.
Uh,
so states have jumped into this problem by creating their own renewable energy
portfolio standards.
So for example,
Massachusetts has a standard,
uh,
that,
is targeting 15% renewable of their total energy demand by 2020.
Ohio is 25%.
By 2025.
A New Mexico is 20% by 2020.
Uh,
California is 20% by 2010,
uh,
in Washington is 15% by 2020.
So that a,
these are legally binding,
uh,
standards and the states are required to figure out how to,
reduce their reliance on fossil fuels while increasing their reliance on
renewable sources.
So if you look at the problem of when you think about a,
its distribution in the nation,
uh,
Texas,
perhaps not surprisingly a has the largest current installed capacity,
uh,
almost 9,000 megawatts followed by Iowa,
California,
Minnesota,
Oregon,
Washington,
New York,
Colorado,
Illinois.
And then Kansas.
You can also see the effect a in this graph of the,
uh,
recession on,
installation of a wind,
uh,
provided electricity.
So 2008,
uh,
I was a far higher in,
new installations in 2009 so that,
uh,
this industry also is subject to the same kinds of limitations as any,
any other sector.
The cost of wind and transmission,
uh,
that is economically available,
might be broken into two different categories on shore and off shore.
It's quite obviously a more expensive to develop further off shore.
Uh,
and,
uh,
the less expensive,
areas are those that are closest to the coastline.
And,
uh,
what we see,
we'll see,
uh,
a case in a few moments,
known as Cape Wind,
uh,
that,
is being proposed for Nantucket sound.
Uh,
and,
uh,
the,
the advantage obviously is that,
uh,
this is in federal territory,
so that,
uh,
no private property needs to be purchased.
Uh,
so that the,
uh,
the quantity available offshore is believed to be,
just about the same as his onshore.
Uh,
but the difficulty of,
of,
uh,
getting,
a wind project off the ground on private property,
uh,
as we'll see in a few moments,
compared to offshore is,
is really,
uh,
quite significant.
So many people are now arguing for a 20% target by 2030 as,
as a,
a,
a goal for,
for wind based energy.
So how do we,
uh,
if we choose this as a target had,
how do we get there and what would be the influence on our use of alternative,
uh,
sources of energy.
So if we have a no new wind,
you can see in this chart,
uh,
than our reliance and natural gas,
coal,
nuclear,
hydro,
uh,
and current wind would look something like this with wind and the green,
but at 20% wins scenario would predominantly cause us to,
uh,
reduce our reliance on coal.
Uh,
but also some of our reliance on natural gas and nuclear.
And why nuclear?
Well,
because many of the reactors are going to be approaching the a,
the end of their licensed periods.
Uh,
and many of them,
as we discussed last week,
uh,
are beyond their 30 to 40 year licensing period.
So we're going to be phasing out nuclear and depending upon,
uh,
the,
incentives for investment in new nuclear plants,
uh,
the,
the future growth is going to be impeded not just by the extraordinary capital
costs and the incremental cost of,
of,
uh,
securing loans for nuclear given,
given its uncertainty.
Uh,
but,
uh,
also also the,
problems of,
uh,
simply the amount of time it takes to build a nuclear plant.
If we rely more heavily on wind,
we need to think about how to get transmission facilities,
transmission lines in close proximity to the,
the key sources of wind.
So that obviously as you look at the United States,
you find,
uh,
a wind capacity varies geographically,
the coastal areas.
A Washington,
uh,
Portland or excuse me,
Oregon,
California,
uh,
the east coast and the Gulf coast,
or are the predominant,
uh,
sites for,
for offshore development in the mid,
mid western United States as the predominant location for,
for,
uh,
development,
non coastal areas.
And this creates a,
uh,
a problem,
particularly for the Midwest because the Midwest is not an,
uh,
population center in the nation.
So that a transmission as needed to relieve congestion in the existing system,
to improve system reliability for all customers,
uh,
to increase access to lower cost energy,
but also to,
uh,
act access new and a remote generation resources so that if the,
20% scenario by 2030 is,
is followed,
oh,
this is going to have a very significant effect on co two emissions from the
electricity sector.
Uh,
so that,
uh,
this is,
is thought of as a,
uh,
a really,
important,
uh,
type of investment.
Now,
a citing a often creates a,
an enormous complex on normally complex,
uh,
a set of rules and regulations that have to be followed in order to,
to gain permits,
uh,
from the federal government,
state governments and local governments.
The predominant concerns about development include visual impacts,
a property value impacts affects on local wildlife and habitat,
a turbine or a rotor noise,
uh,
and,
and land use,
uh,
potential,
effects on adjacent land uses.
So when generation is,
uh,
for example,
responsible for about 0.03% of human caused avian mortality,
particularly in,
uh,
among passerines and,
and,
and bats.
And that mortality has been found to be higher than expected,
but the only in certain areas of the,
uh,
of the world and certain a high elevation zones,
a mountain peaks and also a mountain passes.
So that these are the predominant,
uh,
concerns that,
that,
uh,
cause litigation,
people are also worried about the amount of area that it's going to take in
order to reach this objective of 20% by 2030.
Uh,
and the actual footprint,
uh,
that,
has been measured and is being used by the proponents of,
of wind energy is really quite small.
Uh,
so about a total acreage of about 15 million acres,
you know,
roughly about the size of a Rhode Island or,
or anchorage.
Uh,
so that,
uh,
the,
deceptive,
a aspect of that statistic is that,
uh,
the conflict that surrounds this is not generated by the site,
development,
uh,
and the amount of area,
the law of the land area or the,
uh,
ocean area that has to be disturbed in order to put the facilities.
And it's generated by its visibility,
uh,
predominantly by people's impressions that I find to be really quite curious.
I was,
I was driving to work this morning and,
and uh,
admiring the,
the wind turbine that was just put up a over here next to the Q bridge.
Uh,
and was thinking about that and thinking about people's acceptance or,
or preferences to view landscapes a without towers generally.
And as a kind of surveyed the landscape quickly,
I was looking at the old coal fired power plant next to the Q bridge.
Uh,
then I was looking at,
uh,
the transmission lines,
that a line next to it.
I was looking at the bridge itself.
Really an industrialized landscape.
Probably not a good thing to say to people here for Yale bulldog days.
Uh,
they're very beautiful parts of new haven and the university has a central
source of a new haven's beauty.
Uh,
but that part of new haven is,
is not,
it's a,
it's one of the most industrialized zones,
uh,
in,
in Connecticut.
Uh,
but there are stands this new wind turbine,
a gleaming white,
uh,
and actually it's,
it's dwarfed by other stacks,
smokestacks and,
uh,
the transmission lines nearby.
But people have,
uh,
problems with towers generally.
Uh,
and I was wondering about that.
And I've worked on tower siting problems in the past.
Uh,
and I,
I use the example when we had the lecture on,
on land preservation of the controversy over the Olympic Games and northern New
York,
uh,
where the,
90 and 70 meters ski jump were proposed that a almost brought the Olympic Games
to a halt because of a threatened litigation by the Sierra club and the aversion
there was the loss of the sense of,
of a natural landscape.
And a,
this is very much a,
a prominent part of the argument on the part of,
of uh,
land owners in the coastal area,
uh,
that looks out over Nantucket's sound.
They're worried about the view,
they're worried about the visibility.
Somehow they think it's going to diminish the sense of naturalness of that
landscape,
uh,
and that's provoked their,
their litigation so that,
uh,
there are other kinds of towers that we seem to accept.
But,
uh,
you know,
it may be a function of whether or not we can get up into the tower to take a
look.
Many people up in lake placid eventually accepted a 300 foot towers,
a ski jump,
uh,
that,
was immediately adjacent to a wilderness area.
But a part of the fascination was,
well,
this is a,
this is for,
for sport.
Uh,
but it also is going to give the opportunity to create an observation deck that
people could go up to.
I was thinking about other towers that we seem to readily accept and more
urbanized environments,
residential towers,
office buildings,
uh,
or even the Eiffel Tower.
So that a,
you know,
what is it about towers and our sense of naturalness that provokes this kind of
reaction.
Also worked on,
uh,
communication towers and electrical,
electrical transmission lines,
the demand high towers.
And,
uh,
these are,
these are commonly fought,
uh,
with a great energy,
just,
uh,
just as people are fighting the,
the,
uh,
wind turbines,
so that,
uh,
that would be the subject of a,
a,
a great,
uh,
senior essay.
By the way,
if anybody is looking around for one next year,
uh,
think about also the nature of property rights to wind,
and to solar radiation.
So a does the developer,
for example,
have the right to block access to a resource such as wind or solar,
radiation,
uh,
or water.
If you live upstream and uh,
uh,
you decide you want to put a dam in a,
in a,
in a river or sand,
remember,
uh,
the,
the shifting sands on barrier islands.
And remember,
uh,
as you,
if you fly out of new haven over the coastline and you see these groins that are
set up to,
to traps sand as it moves along the coastline and that causes the San deficit
downstream so that the person that lives next to you,
it has to build a groin so he can catch sand to prevent his shoreline from a
road eroding the same basic principle here.
So that if I build a structure,
a perhaps a high rise building,
the blocks,
uh,
your,
access to wind a,
or even if I build a high rise building and it,
and it blocks your access to solar radiation,
uh,
do you have the right to,
to,
uh,
take me to court and,
either to prevent the development or,
uh,
to,
do I have the right to demand that a,
you compensate me for my property loss in value?
Well,
common law law passed by a by a courts is really unclear on,
on the matter unless there's clear malicious intent.
So unlike a underground minerals,
uh,
no one can extract wind or solar radiation from your property without your
consent.
And I want you to think about the lecture.
Uh,
several weeks ago when I considered the horse whisperer out in Wyoming,
uh,
and the extraordinarily rapid development of coal bed methane gas being
extracted,
a because the federal government sold off the underlying property rights,
uh,
to private corporations who then,
basically had the right to transfer,
uh,
their,
their production equipment to build towers on people's ranches on their private
lands.
So the,
uh,
the,
the story was the horse whisperer woke up to a construction crews bulldozing
roads over their property and outraged thought that,
uh,
he had,
the right to call the police and stop the development when he didn't,
because those,
uh,
those gas extraction companies had purchased the rights legitimately from the
government.
Well,
in,
in this case are the,
uh,
wind or solar radiation rights,
similarly,
uh,
owned as common property by the federal government.
Uh,
and the answer is no.
So that a,
you would have the opportunity,
uh,
to prevent somebody from coming onto your land,
and building a,
a,
a wind turbine.
But it kind of an interesting comparison here,
the way that law is structured to,
to,
to allocate common property rights.
Uh,
to,
uh,
the private sector for energy development.
So think about a wind capacity and,
uh,
the,
the desirability of different areas of the country.
And,
uh,
also think about the nature of private development in the coastal zone.
And I remember,
uh,
the,
California oil spills and to how the tar and the oil would wash up on the
beaches.
And it was kind of interesting.
You know,
you'd go for a run on the beach and,
and,
uh,
you get back to your house or wherever you're staying and,
your,
your feet are covered by a tar.
Even today.
They,
in some parts of California,
they're covered by tar from the Santa Barbara oil spills back in the 1970s.
Uh,
so that,
uh,
these tend to be highly a developable properties,
highly valued property.
Uh,
and if they are,
uh,
the side of residential,
structures,
you're guaranteed to have a fight for any significant offshore development.
So there's an interesting kind of coincidence here of,
of uh,
uh,
high end property,
people that,
uh,
are likely to have values,
that,
uh,
are instinctively to protect the coastal zone,
as well as to protect the naturalness of the views from their private property
so that this conflict is the source of,
of,
uh,
litigation and also legislation.
So the top 10 energy,
excuse me,
the,
uh,
this is a repeat slide.
Here are the top 10,
uh,
states for a wind energy potential.
The last slide I showed you was a top 10 states for,
for current generating capacity.
So Texas,
Kansas,
Montana,
Nebraska,
uh,
and mid western states,
and a,
and particularly in the coastal zone as well,
South Dakota,
North Dakota,
Iowa,
Wyoming,
Oklahoma,
New Mexico.
It's a very interesting that a,
these have the highest capacity,
uh,
but they tend not to be close to where the majority of people in the u s live.
The jump ahead here.
Hmm.
So here's the scenario.
Uh,
offshore development versus land based development.
the projections are that the majority of of new capacity will come from onshore
or land based development.
Uh,
that creates all the political conflict because of questions about how to manage
private property rights.
Uh,
so that,
uh,
if you look at the,
the quantity available offshore and onshore,
and you look at the,
uh,
the,
the relative,
uh,
wind speed in,
in these areas,
you see that the land based,
uh,
is,
is going to likely generate more gigawatts then the offshore.
So what are the,
uh,
the key benefits here?
Well,
uh,
benefits to the environment,
benefits in terms of of uh,
reduced air pollution from fossil fuels.
And,
uh,
there's no question about the fact that we'll be facing increased coal
generation coal power generation,
uh,
that is going to,
give us,
uh,
problems with particulate matter,
sulfur and nitrogen oxides.
Uh,
and remember that statistic that I told you last week that,
uh,
Eh,
this is a really important statistic,
uh,
particularly relative to the health effects of coal.
Uh,
between 30 and 60,000.
People are estimated in a variety of peer reviewed.
And I think highly defensible studies,
uh,
they,
suffer premature death in the United States every year,
uh,
due to coal production.
So that a,
you compare that to nuclear,
uh,
you compare that to a mortality estimates from,
from a wind or solar development.
And there,
there really is no contest in terms of climate.
Uh,
the,
uh,
reduce co two emissions are estimated to be about 825 million metric tons per
year.
Uh,
if the 20% increase over 20% of our electricity is produced by 2030,
a reduced water,
uh,
reduced coal use,
a reduced cost per kilowatt hour,
hour,
and also the increased tax revenues that'll be generated to local communities.
So if you build a wind turbine on your property,
you're going to have to pay the local government to property taxes,
uh,
on your revenue and also you're going to be paying the federal government,
taxes on,
on the revenue.
So the,
uh,
the future of wind,
as I mentioned earlier,
is likely to have the greatest influence on our reliance on coal,
uh,
but,
could also affect our reliance on nuclear.
There's a lot of concern among environmentalists over avian mortality.
So it's important to think about the different causes of avian mortality.
And it's quite striking that,
uh,
mortality from buildings and windows.
And these are deaths per 100.
These are 80 and deaths.
Uh,
uh,
so that,
you see that the majority are being caused by birds flying into buildings and
windows followed by house cats,
a high transmission lines,
vehicles,
uh,
pesticides.
Actually,
the pesticide a estimated is low.
Uh,
I worked on a panel that,
uh,
addressed the question about,
several of the largest,
uh,
most produced a insecticides in,
in the world.
And,
uh,
they are responsible for very significant avian losses,
communication towers and wind turbines.
Uh,
if they reach this 20% by 2030,
our projected to be really quite low.
Now,
that doesn't mean that we don't pay attention to them and legally we have an
obligation to do so.
Uh,
and that's because of the endangered species act.
And this will come to play.
And when we talk in a few minutes about,
uh,
the Nantucket sound case,
that,
uh,
might influence the,
the piping plover that nests in the adjacent shorelines.
Also,
there's concerns about,
uh,
noise.
Now how windy or excuse me,
how noisy are they compared to other,
other sources of noise?
So if you,
uh,
if you look at a jet aircraft at 250 meters,
he looked at a pneumatic drill.
You look at a truck,
uh,
an office,
a car at 40 meters,
uh,
then,
and you find a wind power plant at 350 meters,
uh,
would be,
about equivalent to a quiet bedroom,
uh,
or perhaps a car operating at 40 miles an hour,
that drives by 40 meters away,
excuse me,
a hundred meters away.
So,
you know,
the,
the implications of this are kind of interesting in terms of managing a noise.
How might you do that?
Well you could think about a using zoning,
uh,
you could demand very large lot zoning and remember the case and the Adirondacks
where one new house for,
uh,
perhaps,
40% of the private land in the Adirondacks,
40% of two and a half million acres.
So one new house requires 43 acres up in the Adirondacks.
So what would it take you to get a,
a buffer between the turbine location on land and a separation distance that
we're would reduce the decibel level on adjacent properties?
We can,
you can imagine designing a zoning ordinance that would,
would allow you to control noise on adjacent lands in that fashion.
Well,
so that,
uh,
it's important for you to think too about the structure of the u s utility
industry.
There are about 200 investor owned utilities in the nation,
70,
large municipal and federal or state systems,
50 rural generation and transmission cooperatives,
uh,
and 3000 local distribution companies.
I think also about Def,
uh,
who are the dominant consumers of energy in the United States.
It turns out that the federal government is the largest single consumer of
electricity in the world.
Uh,
the federal agency,
uh,
electricity consumption in 2005 was more than 55,000 gigawatt hours,
which would equate to approximately 18 gigawatts of wind capacity.
So federal agencies were encouraged to meet an executive order,
uh,
goal of 2.5% of them site electricity from new renewable energy sources by the
end of 2005.
By the way,
we've not talked about the executive orders in the class,
but I'm going to pause here just to point out that that a law may be established
at a very different levels of government,
state,
local,
federal,
uh,
but,
also in may be established by regulation.
So EPA has the legal authority to establish regulations and the executive branch
of the government,
the office of the president has the legal authority to establish executive
orders,
uh,
that must be complied with within the federal government,
by federal agencies.
So that in this case,
uh,
to meet an order of,
the,
uh,
the order goal of 2.5%.
This goal was actually exceeded a,
with a final tally of about 6.9% of electricity consumed,
was derived from renewable sources.
So that's kind of an interesting idea.
So figure out who are the largest consumers and then set goals for them and then
challenge them a set up a competition.
And,
uh,
we've seen that competitive spirit work here in the college as well,
so that to colleges are trying to,
not just to reduce their,
their uh,
uh,
waste and to increase their rate of recycling,
but they're also trying to reduce their energy consumption so that,
uh,
now the federal agencies are all challenged to try to figure out how they can
increase their,
a renewable component of their energy consumption portfolios.
Uh,
there's also the concept of renewable energy credits and renewable energy
certificates and these are,
are tradable non-tangible energy commodities in the u s that represent proof
that one megawatt hour of electricity was generated from an eligible renewable
energy solar resource,
uh,
which would include solar,
wind,
geothermal,
hydro,
biomass or energy derived from hydrogen fuel cells.
Uh,
now I want to talk for a few moments about the,
the problem,
uh,
up in Nantucket sound.
Uh,
and this is a,
a,
a project Cape Wind that was initiated in 2001,
uh,
when,
this company decided that they wanted to put up about 130 turbines and that
Nantucket sound and it,
uh,
the state of Rhode Island,
by the way,
has taken a very different path,
not just reacting to a developer's proposal.
Uh,
but,
uh,
Rhode Island has taken the initiative to a zone parts of its offshore territory.
Uh,
and,
uh,
they have a designated a,
a company,
a developer as a preferred developer,
uh,
and,
have now proposed about a one point $5 billion farm in eastern Rhode Island.
So states could,
uh,
you know,
basically be reactive in their,
uh,
approach to developing wind energy.
Just wait for the developers to show up.
Uh,
but Rhode Island is taking a,
a,
a very different,
uh,
approach to this so that they are,
are in a way acting as the developer themselves.
So if you take a look at this wind map of,
of uh,
the,
uh,
southern New England coastline,
you see that there are areas particularly,
uh,
off of Rhode Island and particularly here in Nantucket sound,
which are really quite,
uh,
quite suitable in terms of the amount of wind energy that that is available,
for development.
So the Cape Wind,
uh,
proposal,
would involve,
as I said,
130 different turbines.
Uh,
and on average it would provide about 75% of the entire electrical requirements
for the Cape and the islands.
So,
uh,
I don't know if this is going to work,
but let me see if I can show you a youtube video here
just briefly.
Now,
here is a,
uh,
a,
seen,
uh,
that,
shows a boat of sightseer just moving through a,
a wind farm off the coast of Denmark.
Uh,
just to give you a sense of what it would be like.
Now,
there are questions here about a navigation,
uh,
their questions about interference with others' property rights.
So offshore waters,
if you're beyond the three mile jurisdictional limit,
uh,
then it becomes federal lands.
If you're between the mean high water mark,
uh,
and the three mile zone that is state land.
And,
uh,
what this means is because these,
these power lines,
we'll have to lie beneath the surface as they run from the turbines back to the
mainland,
uh,
that they clearly will cross from federal lands into state lands.
Uh,
and then they will cross private lands.
Or in some instances they will be,
uh,
require a dredging,
a wetland areas,
uh,
up onto a local government property so that local,
state,
federal,
and private property rights are all at play.
And in this case,
so that,
uh,
there are also issues that arise from conflicts with fishermen who may have the
right to a lobster in this area.
Perhaps they,
they,
uh,
use a form of fishing that drags over the,
the,
uh,
the bottom.
Uh,
these are known as the Nantucket shoals,
uh,
known to be,
a former,
uh,
clamming areas.
Uh,
the,
the Nantucket area,
the buzzards bay area is,
is,
has a long and rich history as a,
as a,
as a fishing,
uh,
being important as a commercially viable fishing,
area so that,
uh,
they're also potential conflicts here with,
with the air rights,
with respect to,
uh,
flight paths so that the Federal Aviation Administration is also involved.
Uh,
so that this is really a,
uh,
illegal,
a quagmire in a way.
It's a cobweb of,
of rights,
uh,
that,
touch off jurisdiction on the part of,
of three different levels of government in many a local jurisdictions and a
different different state and federal agencies as well.
So the,
the location in the sound that is being proposed,
uh,
is pretty much between and to the north of Nantucket,
which lies over here on the south,
uh,
on the right side and the bottom and a in Martha's vineyard,
roughly five to six miles off.
For now,
this has become most controversial because that is close enough so that the,
the towers would be visible from a shoreline areas.
So they've completed six years of environmental studies of the surface and
subsurface geology when tied waves,
sediment transport patterns benthic a in and shellfish resources,
fish habitat,
a commercial and recreational fisheries and marine mammals and threatened and
endangered species.
And,
uh,
what,
what's interesting about this is also that they've been quite successful.
Cape Wind,
the corporation has been successful in federal court litigation.
Uh,
so that,
uh,
all of the permitting on the part of local governments and,
the state government,
uh,
is now complete.
This also fell under the,
uh,
requirements of the National Environmental Policy Act,
that demanded that an environmental impact statement be prepared.
And,
uh,
this was,
done,
uh,
with,
with great care.
Uh,
and it also pointed to all of the possible effects on fish,
on,
on wildlife,
on endangered species.
Uh,
but,
uh,
also,
was clear in identifying conflicts,
uh,
between,
the developers and,
and,
uh,
the,
the wind turbine,
uh,
turbines,
with,
uh,
the,
the various interest groups that,
uh,
currently have rights to a,
to use the areas so that a state permitting status is complete a,
as of the fall of,
uh,
2008.
And,
uh,
the,
there's a facility siting board in Massachusetts,
there is a state environmental quality,
a permitting process that was required to be complied with.
Uh,
they're also our state wetlands laws in Massachusetts,
uh,
that are particularly protective of coastal wetlands.
Uh,
so that,
uh,
all of these permits have been.
Now granted the federal permitting status is managed by the Minerals Management
Service,
uh,
and that sits within the department of the interior.
Uh,
so that,
uh,
favorable draft impact statement was prepared in,
in 2004.
Uh,
and then it released a favorable draft,
uh,
or exceeding.
That should be a final environmental impact statement.
Uh,
on January 15th of 2000,
uh,
2008 favorable comments on the part of different organizations including the
Natural Resources Defense Council,
uh,
known for being very protective of,
of coastal areas around the nation and being very concerned about issues of
climate change,
keep wind,
NRDC argued is to our knowledge the largest single source of supply side
reductions in CO2 currently proposed in the United States and perhaps the world
and the Department of Energy Assistant Secretary said as the first shallow water
off shore project under a review in the United States utility scale projects
like Cape Wind are important to our national interest and a crucial first step
to building a domestic globally competitive when supply.
And a another,
a former,
uh,
US Department of Energy Assistant Secretary,
and now a Massachusetts Secretary of environmental,
uh,
officers.
It,
uh,
Susan Tierney comment of the Cape Wind draft environmental impact statement is
thorough.
It's detailed to identify as analyzes and describes a wide variety or wide array
of impacts with great care,
detail and comprehensiveness.
Indeed,
it's one of the most thorough that I've ever seen.
So wide support.
Among a variety of different,
uh,
agencies.
Now.
Uh,
right now,
uh,
the,
Cape Wind Company is awaiting a decision on the part of Ken Salazar who was the
secretary of the interior.
Ken Salazar,
uh,
is responsible for the National Park Service,
that also sits within the,
uh,
separate booth than the Department of the interior.
And you might ask a question of,
well,
what does the park service have to do with the permitting for facilities such as
this?
Well,
the park service curiously,
is responsible,
uh,
because of the national historic preservation act.
Uh,
this requires a,
that a historic facilities in the United States be,
be,
uh,
identified and ranked for their relative importance.
And if they're found to be of national significance,
they are eligible to be placed on the national registry of historic places.
So that the,
uh,
the secretary of the interior,
and I have to jump ahead here for a second.
The secretary of Interior had the ability,
uh,
to,
to uh,
uh,
decide that,
either the national significance of this as native American burial grounds,
uh,
was,
so high that it would be designated and therefore this wind farm would not be
allowed to go forward.
And he's committed to reaching a conclusion about this,
uh,
within the next two weeks.
So pay attention to,
uh,
to the press.
It will turn out to be quite interesting.
So the,
uh,
secretary went out and took a look at the,
at the site,
uh,
several months ago and,
and uh,
uh,
has held a variety of press conferences over the past couple of weeks that
demonstrate that he is really on the edge not knowing whether or not this he
should be pursuing the national,
uh,
objective and increasing the renewable energy,
a portfolio of the United States.
I'm going to have to jump ahead here because I've got way too much material.
So forgive me
or to talk just a moment about comparing this case to two other kinds of
problems that we've discussed in class or that you may be familiar with.
And the idea of the government role of providing either credits or subsidies.
So I want you to think about,
uh,
the,
the relative historical absence of federal subsidy of renewed renewable energy
sources and compare that to,
uh,
the subsidies that have occurred for the oil industry.
And the,
perhaps the greatest subsidy that I can think of.
A is in part a reflection on what happened.
Uh,
when,
uh,
major,
automobile company,
a tire company in oil companies,
uh,
in the early 19 hundreds,
went around to different cities and purchase up,
uh,
the,
the trolley lines,
uh,
the,
the tram lines,
they purchase them up,
uh,
as a way of,
of a diminishing,
uh,
the public's ability to use public transit,
and to develop an increased reliance on automobiles.
Now think also about the national costs,
uh,
to maintain and build or rebuild our national highway system.
And,
uh,
where would the auto industry in the oil industry be in the United States,
if that,
uh,
were not accomplished by our tax dollars.
So now I think about,
uh,
the,
the highway system,
uh,
as being really a,
an enormous subsidy for the oil industry as well as for the auto industries.
I think also about to how we have,
uh,
in the past year a subsidized a,
the auto industry and banks as well.
So that,
uh,
how do we come to choose to subsidize a certain private ventures and,
and not others.
We have a clear problem that,
uh,
we need to deal with their,
I also want you to think about a,
a variety of different,
uh,
conclusions with respect to land use regulation.
We've looked at land use regulation and we've looked at problems of controlling
private behavior,
taking away rights,
uh,
from individuals on private land.
Uh,
and,
and I want you to think about,
uh,
the opportunities for a variety of new land use and,
regulation and subdivision regulations,
schemes that might,
a zone lands for wind farms.
Uh,
so that,
uh,
if you think back on the Adirondack Park Zoning scheme where they did zone
certain areas for industrial growth,
they zoned other areas for agricultural growth.
Uh,
food farms,
uh,
that,
why not the concept of a zoning for,
for wind farms.
Now you could argue that,
uh,
well if you're going to zone wind farms,
you need to think about how you're going to manage the externalities that might
fall onto adjacent landowners.
Well,
that that could be dealt with,
as I mentioned them a few moments ago and a variety of ways.
Uh,
and,
uh,
these might be,
these might include the offering development credits to adjacent landowners to
increase density elsewhere.
In other words,
a transferable development rights might be,
uh,
a component of these land use regulations.
So the adjacent land owners are actually given a bonus.
They're given a development,
uh,
right,
that,
uh,
would be assignable to an area that was zoned to receive increased density.
Uh,
these would be bankable,
so they wouldn't have to physically develop it.
They could put the credit into a bank and somebody else in another developer who
wanted to build in that high density zone,
uh,
could purchase that credit.
So there's a potential here to,
to uh,
to tie zoning for wind farms to transferable development rights.
Uh,
require minimum acreage is a hundred acres,
200 acres,
a thousand acres,
whatever.
It would be a and regulate lot dimensions.
So you could imagine a thousand acres in a,
a relatively narrow strip of land are going on for a,
for miles.
Uh,
but you could also think about how you might design a lot dimension requirements
in a way that would ensure that you would have a separation distance from the
turbine to the adjacent landowners.
That might sense a offense.
We also need to think carefully about zoning for new transmission lines.
Uh,
and,
uh,
zoning zoning in corridors,
is always been a part of,
of a local and state land use regulations.
Uh,
so that I think about where the corridors are right here in new haven.
we have a real corridor that also serves as a highway corridor.
It's also a powerline corridor.
Uh,
so that,
uh,
you know,
building a new transmission lines and areas where rail and highly corridors or
already exist.
Make a lot of sense.
If we have to buy new land to create new transmission lines,
that's going to be an extraordinarily expensive venture.
Uh,
and,
uh,
think about,
again,
this problem of having the,
the production being located in distance,
uh,
in,
in large distance away from,
uh,
the,
the points of,
of higher population densities and,
and,
uh,
consumption.
So another conclusion that I want you to walk away with here is with respect to
property rights so that offshore development is going to be much easier to
accomplish,
uh,
the non shore development.
Now here we are in 2010,
the Cape Wind developers made their proposal in 2001 they've wandered their way
through this regulatory permitting process for,
for nine years.
There's a lesson there.
The lesson,
uh,
is,
has been followed in a variety of other regulatory contexts and it's called one
stop shopping,
one stop shopping for a permit.
You know,
what if we had one,
uh,
renewable,
agency renewable energy agency that had all of the authority to grant the
permits and yes,
they would have to consult with state representatives,
they would have to consult with local representatives.
Uh,
but a developer could go through this process perhaps in three or four years,
uh,
instead of nine years,
the capital carrying costs that are involved here when you're purchasing
property,
uh,
and,
trying to figure out,
uh,
what state of technology you're going to apply.
Capital costs here are enormous and can be discouraging.
I mentioned the coal bed methane issue and,
and thank distinctively about how that coal bed methane property,
right,
uh,
was,
was allowed to be purchased by the private sector.
Uh,
whereas,
uh,
the,
the wind property,
right,
like the solar property right,
uh,
is generally assigned,
with a surface lands.
Uh,
so who has the right to block wind,
who has the right to block solar radiation and are these legitimate bases for
civil actions as news nuisances.
Now I'd like to close by having you think about,
uh,
damages and how we calculate damages.
And as you think about every case that we've discussed in this term,
uh,
when we think about environmental effects,
you should be thinking about the magnitude of the effect.
And you should be thinking,
thinking about the distribution of the effect.
So think about a,
uh,
this,
this comparison between nuclear power on the one hand and wind energy on the
other.
Uh,
what are the adverse environmental effects from a wind power likely to be while
we've gone through a variety of them,
uh,
biological resources,
a land area that's going to be required,
uh,
but they all pale in response to,
the problems associated with constructing and operating a nuclear power plants
and then figuring out what to do with the waste.
And one way to think about distribution is just to think about,
uh,
how something spreads geographically,
but think about distribution,
uh,
in a temporal way as,
as well.
So that,
uh,
the,
a fact that the environmental protection agency is required to develop a,
a,
a nuclear waste disposal plan,
uh,
to cover 1 million years,
for the management of the Yucca Mountain a storage facility,
uh,
that has to do with the persistence of,
of,
uh,
the radiant nuclides,
particularly,
uh,
plutonium isotopes.
I mean,
think about that.
Uh,
the persistence of the problem over time is another way to consider
distribution.
Uh,
so,
uh,
the consideration of magnitude and distribution by,
as well,
by thinking about questions of equity,
who are these damages going to fall onto?
A,
how should they be managed?
Uh,
and some people are much more capable of managing risk than other people are.
so they can buy higher quality insurance than,
than,
uh,
poorer people can.
So,
uh,
once again,
magnitude and distribution for a variety of different kinds of effects.
So,
uh,
the,
the effect in my opinion on wildlife and fish noise on aesthetics and vibration,
uh,
on the shadow and flicker effects,
that,
uh,
are being studied alone with a vibration affects right here in the Yale medical
school.
Uh,
there is a claim by the way,
that,
uh,
these wind turbine farms create vibrations that you can't actually feel,
but they're strong enough if you are in close enough proximity to these fields,
uh,
to have,
your,
your sleep disturbed.
And also on the property values and an on recreational access.
These are the core points of contention,
but compared to managing nuclear waste,
uh,
over,
hundreds of thousands of years,
these seem like relatively minor issues.
And I'd like to close with just one thought and that is,
uh,
as you think about difficult tradeoffs such as this,
I encourage you to,
to consider the idea of reversibility.
Reversability isn't a concept that has been built into a variety of different
laws,
so that a,
under many different statutes,
uh,
the government is required to consider whether or not the effect is reversible.
So,
uh,
plutonium,
the creation of a,
uh,
plutonium and,
he's not a reversible decision.
And,
uh,
given that,
length of persistence,
uh,
the construction of a coal fired power plant such as you see here on the upper
left,
yeah,
that's reversible.
You could pull that apart.
But if we look at our,
uh,
our history of rehabilitation of a damaged sites in industrial facilities in the
nation,
uh,
they tend not to be rebuilt because they're so highly contaminated.
Now think,
uh,
think about the disassembly of a turbine farm or the disassembly of a solar
generating facilities such as this,
uh,
out in the new banks,
New Mexico desert.
Uh,
these are easily disassembled.
So just consider the idea of reversibility,
uh,
as you think about how these kinds of choices might be made.
Okay,
well,
that is the end of lecture 23 and a,
we'll wrap up with a final lecture on Thursday.
Thank you.